All the stuff you
see in video games,
we're gonna show you how
to do in real life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: One of the
most recognizable figures
in the sports world.
ANNOUNCER: There's
one name that's
synonymous with skateboarding.
It's Tony Hawk.
ANNOUNCER: Legendary Tony Hawk.
Tony Hawk!
TONY HAWK: I was 14 years
old when I went pro.
The very first
time that I created
a new trick, that was the buzz.
That was the high that I
chased the rest of my life.
Skateboarding is a lifestyle,
a sport, and an art form
all at once.
In this MasterClass,
I am breaking down
foundational skate tricks and
some of my own signature tricks
for the very first time.
We're going to start from the
very beginning, the first time
you step on the skateboard.
The first step of the ollie is
pushing down on your back foot
until the tail just
hits the ground.
And that sends your
board straight up.
It feels magical.
You did this with your feet.
The three types of skateboarding
that we are covering
are street, park, and vert.
Lizzie Armanto will take
you to the next level
of intermediate tricks
in park skating.
And Riley Hawk will guide you
through complicated and technical
street tricks.
The key to a McTwist
is in the snap.
I reach down for my board, and
I turn my head, immediately
snapping it.
If you have the snap, you have
the grab, you have the spin,
you can do it.
It's just one that you
didn't get to see the landing
zone the whole time.
School was not a
pleasant experience.
I got picked on a lot.
And then I skated.
When I found skateboarding,
I found my voice.
You don't have to follow
the textbook of exactly
how to live your life.
Skateboarding can be a
great lesson in your life,
a lesson in perseverance, a
lesson in self-confidence,
a lesson in belief.
You don't have to
be a pro skater.
But you can carry
these lessons with you
throughout your life
in so many other ways.
I'm Tony Hawk, and
this is my MasterClass.